hubble will die one day obviously hubble
the person is already dead but
the hubble telescope will die one day
and we have to both be mentally and
astronomically prepared something will
wear out on hubble space telescope
basically either calibration lamps or
some of the fuel to change which
direction it's pointing in it will
eventually stop working we will no
longer be able to get images from hubble
sunrise uh over the hubble space
telescope eliminating the golden solar
rays those arrays to be retracted for
the final time uh a few hours from now
nasa esa the canadian space telescope
have got a new hubble
in the pipeline it's called james webb
space telescope and uh this is what it
looks like it's infrared not optical
unlike hubble so it's not gonna be a
true follow-up because hubble looks in
the uv and the optical and in the
infrared whereas james webb will look
out the very far
infrared james webb will be at the
lagrange two point so i know that 60
symbols has done a lagrangian video
before but basically a lagrange point is
a stable point in a two-body system so
we have the sun and we have the earth
it's going around the sun and basically
there are five points in those orbits at
which if you put something
it wouldn't move relative to the earth
and sun so it would stay where it was so
l2 is sort of beyond earth away from the
sun and basically it will have a 365 day
year the same as the earth but it will
be orbiting further out it will be
launched in ariane 5 which is a really
really successful esa rocket
and then they're going to give it a
little burst and then i'll get it get it
enough energy to get to l2
but really really slowly so what they'll
do is it's kind of like going up a hill
if you will so they'll give it enough
energy to boost it up the hill but so
much so it'll slow down slow down and
understand until it reaches the very top
at which point it will stop
and the thing is like a really good putt
yeah like a really really good put yeah
um that just sort of stops right on the
edge and then falls in in that time
the antenna will fold out so it can talk
to earth and then the whole thing moves
upwards as well and it's called the
spacecraft bus they call it the whole
thing will move up and make room for all
of the equipment down below the sun
shields will all fold out as well this
is this huge tennis court sized five
layer intricate sun shield
this which we call the secondary mirror
so it happens light comes in here
bounces off here bounces onto the
secondary and then into the center where
it's detected that will also be up here
during launch and will get folded down
to the right position
the mirror itself so this segmented
array
will also fold out from being folded up
inside the rocket so what they've had to
do is they've have to design the shape
of the mirror
so that it is the wrong shape at room
temperature but by the time that it gets
to like the vacuum of space it will cool
and warp to the right shape
it feels like they've made this too
complicated like they seem like they've
been too ambitious am i wrong i i get
that feeling as well but i think it's
because
i i'm not an engineer space scientist
engineer so i can't comprehend what is
too complicated you know let's leave it
for the literally the rocket scientists
to tell us you know what's too
complicated they have such belief that
this will work
so the astronomical community you know
has faith in them and says okay well
this is what i want to do with it then
there's
a huge long list of things that could go
wrong it could
just
blow up being trying to be launched the
antenna couldn't even fall out the sun
shields might not deploy properly the
mirror might not fold out properly the
secondary mirror might not fall out
probably the whole thing might not move
up it might jam like the cryostat to
cool everything might not come on the
electronics might be fried it might get
shook up too much that it might not work
i mean
it's kind of terrifying trying to list
everything that might go wrong but also
exciting
because they've had to
think about how can we stop that from
happening
there's about 10
brand new technologies that have gone
into jwst that haven't been tested
before
everything's already built you know
everything's being tested repeatedly
at nasa goddard which is you know the
washington dc area um their vibration
testing they are testing the solar
shields how they pull out someone said
to me that the the test they'd seen it
happen the other day but it took two
weeks
for the solar shields to fully
open up he said it was like watching
paint dry because you'd go for lunch and
come back and they wouldn't look like
they moved at all
um it's going undergoing so much
rigorous testing to make sure that
everything
can stand up to the launch and
fold out in you know the sort of
situation that it needs to hubble was
optical in uv it had stuff that it could
specifically do but it's limited it can
only see
so far and that's because obviously if
you imagine stars and galaxies are
always giving off optical light
the further away they are the more that
light is redshifted and so hubble can't
actually see
the very distant galaxies
because there's nothing really in the
optical wave lens that it can see
anymore so
we have to look in the infrared i
printed out these to show you so this is
the optical image of the eagle nebula
taken by hubble it is my favorite hubble
image it is beautiful it's of a
star-forming region in the milky way you
can see all the dust clouds it's
absolutely beautiful
on your
right yeah okay
is the infrared image from hubble as
well
and although the optical one is more
sort of visually spectacular the
infrared one is more scientifically
spectacular because you can see through
all the dust and the gas that's in this
nebula and so you can learn more from
the infrared image than you can from the
optical
obviously to get enough light from an
object you have to stare at it
incessantly and
the idea with james webb is that it's
got such a big mirror at 6.5 meters as
opposed to you know hubble's 2.4
that you don't have to stay for very
long at all
so one of the uh
quotes i remember was that if you took
the spitzer space telescope which is
infrared as well
it did an entire survey of galaxies and
it took something like 550 hours of
observing time that's just actually
staring at the sky that's not including
all the time it takes to re-point the
telescope
if you were to do the exact same survey
again with james webb it would take 30
minutes
the other thing it's going to be able to
do
what people hope it will be able to do
is to detect the first signs of life
in our universe you know beyond our own
planet obviously i mean i'm not talking
about sort of you know contacting et or
little green men here what i'm talking
about is
bio signatures you know this is the idea
that you will be able to detect in that
atmosphere say water or oxygen or
carbon dioxide something that we know
on earth is a signature that life is
here the way that they've detected
exoplanets in the past is to have
the exoplanets star here if you're sort
of the kepler spacecraft which is the
one that's been detecting all these
explanations and i am the star then what
happens is you're observing light from
me and you're like yep there's a star
there's definitely a star there and then
a planet moves across uh my face and
basically it will produce a tiny little
dip
in my brightness
in which case you'd be like oh plan it
there
what they'll do now is they'll wait for
it to transit
and they'll wait for the the light from
the star to pass through a teeny tiny
bit of the atmosphere of that planet
and then they will take that light and
split it into its rainbow into its
spectra
they'll take off the light from the star
and they'll be left with the absorption
spectra of the atmosphere of that planet
even if we were very confident that we
had detected
signs of life in an atmosphere
and we said okay this is definitely sort
of
like earth the most earth like we could
possibly ever find say it's a
star exactly like the sun and it's
an earth size and an earth you know
radius planet and everything and it's
got ozone it's got hdr and it's got co2
everything
it might be ten thousand light years
away
and if we were ever going to have a
conversation with these people
i call them people
with this life if they were
intelligent life
it would take us ten thousand years to
send a signal for them to receive it and
ten thousand years to come back so it
would be a 20 000 year wait
for the other side of the conversation
in the paper there's you know the most
earth-like planet every six months
and either that'll be the most earth
light from its mass or from its radius
or from the distance it orbits around
its star or for the fact that the star
is the same as the sun
we've never really found one that fits
all of those
criteria at once it's pretty scary
because it won't launch october 2018
but they already have science proposals
in if you want to do something very
specific that's your science the call
for proposals is november
this year so everybody is already
starting to think
what will i do how will i observe this
how long will it take me
because you have to put all that in the
proposal before someone decides yes or
no you don't you do or don't get time
before it's even
launched before it's even gone to the
launch site like it won't even be in
french guyana before
people put in
telescope proposals
i bet those people are going to be
nervous when other launchers yes
definitely
if your sort of scientific career future
prospects are you know dependent on you
getting the james webb space telescope
time you need that thing to work portion
of the spectrum
we feel right now that there's probably
no real science that we can do with the
wildfield camera at this time
and i'll stop there but the thing about
hubble is that it was launched into low
earth orbit and it was always intended
that it would be visited by astronauts
and so a few years later one of five